so genetics is a broad descriptor but
specifically I think we can use the
molecular biology revolution that is the
manipulation of genes and they have been
crucial in helping us understand both
disease and design better vaccines so by
isolating genes that encode proteins
from infectious organisms we can then
take those jeans and express them to
make new proteins in various different
organisms and that way we can generate
very large amounts of protein with which
to use as a vaccine genetics have also
been used as a way of finding new
proteins for infectious organisms
recently a managing a meningococcal B
vaccine has been developed where the
whole genome for that bacterium was
deciphered and new proteins identified
which could be associated or correlated
with protective immune responses and
from that identification again those
proteins were cloned through molecular
biology and used as the basis of a
vaccine which is proving very promising
again in clinical trials so genetics
have been really quite revolutionary
with our ability to design vaccines in
what I'd like to think both a safe and a
very cost-effective